thank you so much jc all right nothing
says love
like food right jc key to your heart key
to your heart
and um so kayla cooper from joann stores
is back today
to show us how to make some delicious
mini valentine's day donuts and also the
specific heat of my heart
donuts so kayla you already won me over
thank you hey rocky so um what we have
here is our
wilson melting pot we have some little
chocolates to put in there to melt down
and just
you take your your donut and there's two
theories here you can just
dip it in there and that works pretty
good
get it in there really nice you can also
drizzle if you're more of a dainty girl
but you know it's chocolate so
go crazy okay kayla i have a question
can you buy this little mini pot at
joann's because this is cool this is a
cool tool
yes you one of the can i like about it
is you can actually take out this piece
right here and if you let it cool off
you just the chocolate out and you don't
even need wash
really it's so simple clean no double
boiler
none of that crazy stuff yeah this is
great
and that's that simple um
okay so i'm sorry i'm trying to listen
to you and do this right at the same
time now
right now i have a nice little layer of
pink chocolate here and then i guess the
next step is
sprinkles right you can't do valentine's
day without sprinkles
and the great part about you know baking
and valentine's day is
as long as you make it with love you're
doing it right so don't worry about
making it
pretty it tastes good i love that that's
sweet
more more sprinkles okay so what else
can we find at joann's for valentine's
day
you can find the melting pot there you
can find all of our sprinkles we have a
wonderful valentine's day baking
selection right now with cute little
cupcakes and
oh that looks fabulous that's amazing
you see it kayla thank you so much now
all i gotta do is eat it
i do have to give it to my date can i
just eat it myself
oh no nobody shares chocolate come on i
like you kayla
all right thank you so much have you
have a wonderful day
happy valentine's day you too you too
just visit joanns.com for more everybody
las vegas now we'll be right back